[Music]
what i'm going to do
is walk you through um
an assessment of some of the things that
i believe we've learned from
philosophy and cognitive science over
the last few years
which help us to understand the basis of
our own human irrationality
a little better i want to try to explain
why that makes us vulnerable
to fake news and propaganda and
alternative facts and
in effect i'm doing that for a purpose i
want to try
to create for you an opportunity or a
framework
which would allow you to think a little
bit more
critically about scientific issues that
affect
your daily lives of course we're doing
this
entire festival virtually because we are
following
scientific principles that are affecting
our daily lives
and to a certain extent we can see how
fundamentally important that is
but also which gives you an opportunity
in fact to come to terms with some of
the complexities that we're dealing with
and i thought we'd launch by one of my
favorite quotes from einstein time and
again the passion for understanding has
led to the illusion that man is able to
comprehend the objective world
rationally
by pure thought without any empirical
foundations
in short by metaphysics i hope that by
the time we're done
you'll understand where that statement
is coming from and where's einstein has
developed these sentiments
we live in an extraordinary complex
world
so complex in fact that i would deny any
individual human mind can hope to fathom
it
um as humans we've invented
extraordinary social structures to help
us live our lives earn a living
look after us when we're ill take care
of
our money and our finances
a lot of these structures depend on
modern science and technology and
whether we like it or not
scientific and technological issues
pervade
almost our very existence but most of us
don't have the depth of experience or
the expertise to sit in instant judgment
on scientific issues
and honestly that goes for everyone i
trained as a scientist although i gave
up academic science many years ago
but you asked me about the coronavirus
pandemic and i have to tell you that
that's not an area of science in which
i have any familiarity i don't have the
depth of experience or the expertise to
judge
whether advice that i'm getting from the
government for example
is the right advice or the wrong advice
we also
live in extraordinary times uh we've
become familiar with the notion of
of post truth casual lies fake news and
alternative facts
appear to be with us literally every day
everywhere we look whether it's on
social media newspapers news broadcasts
um and what this means is that we can be
very easily misled to a conclusion that
is demonstrably false
and that's a that's obviously a problem
this talk will provide hopefully some
background knowledge in a framework that
will help you think more critically
about scientific issues and i want to
begin
really by going back to
some some structures
developed from philosophy that help us
think about
the complexities of social reality so
the reality of our lived
experience and i want to distinguish
that very clearly from
natural reality physical reality the
natural world we know it's constructed
from particles and forces
it consists of objects such as atoms
mountains
lakes trees and living things um
what i mean is these are the brute facts
which we assume if we could imagine a
scenario whereby
all of humanity disappeared overnight
planet earth was left free of um
if you want to think about it as
contamination by human beings
um the brute facts i would argue we
would quite happily presume would still
exist
even though we didn't so there would
still be
atoms there would still be mountains
trees lakes and living things
but there are also what the american
philosopher john searle
calls institutional facts
these are undeniably real a good example
is
money which let's say is an obsession
of all of us from time to time but money
is an institutional fact
which exists only within a structure of
constitutive rules
they're printed by recognized national
banks they have a certain
combination of inks and colors and
notations but these have been invented
by by us they
if we were to cease to exist overnight
um
these notes these dollar bills would
continue to exist
but money would have no meaning because
without human minds
there is no meaning for this stuff and
it's a
point that john searle explains in his
book the construction of social reality
that institutional facts exist only in
our minds
now there's philosophers who would argue
that even the brute facts
are really based on our perception
anyone who's watched a movie called the
matrix from the late 90s will
know what these philosophers are saying
but the simple truth is that it makes no
logical sense to claim that these brute
facts stop existing when we're not
looking at them or thinking about them
but certainly uh institutional facts if
humanity
were to cease to exist then there is a
sense in which these facts
cease to exist as well i wear a wedding
ring
it's an example of taking um
an aspect of physical reality the
precious metal in this case
making it into a band but of course it
means
a lot more than simply a band of metal
it carries all sorts of connotations in
terms of what's expected of me as a
husband
um in in a marriage and and that's an
institutional fact
marriage doesn't exist without human
beings the metal
will continue to exist now this is
fascinating but we should accept that
social reality is effectively weightless
and invisible
um john searle wrote that one reason we
bear the burden
is that the complex structure of social
reality is so to speak weightless and
invisible
we grow up as children in a culture
where
um we take social reality for granted
um we learn to perceive and use
socially created things like cars and
bathtubs and houses
money restaurants and schools without
thinking of them as
any different from trees and lakes and
rivers and atoms
we don't recognize the special features
of their ontology their basis in
knowledge
and without their about being aware that
they have a special
uh a special nature in the sense of
belonging to
our social reality they seem as natural
to us as stones and water and trees
so this is quite extraordinary so we've
created these structures they're already
very very complex
we take them for granted they're
weightless and invisible
and yet it actually gets worse that is
in a sense already
bad enough um but now add it to
some of the findings recently from
cognitive science
one of which is the conclusion that we
have a tendency as human beings to think
we know more than we really do
uh when faced with asking being asked to
self-assess our
knowledge of of of something like the
operation of a flush
toilet just to pick a mundane example uh
we have a tendency to rate ourselves
quite highly
when we then asked to provide an
explanation well how does a flush toilet
work we say well we push the handle here
and
water goes down there and we start to
lose a little bit of that confidence
if we're given a diagnostic question to
answer
our confidence diminishes a little more
um if we're then presented with an
expert explanation of how a flush toilet
works
we're initially concerned that we really
didn't understand it to begin with but
of course once we've understood the
expert explanation
our confidence increases again but
there's no doubt that this
initial assessment of our own ability
to understand facets of our social
reality
is what cognitive scientists call the
illusion of explanatory depth
we think we know more than we really do
and social reality is so complex that
that's potentially dangerous
uh situation um the basis i'm going to
give you
a series of books i've already given you
john cell
check out this book by stephen sloman
and philip fernbach as well called the
knowledge illusion
and they say there that our success as a
species is based on the collective
intelligence and the ability to
collaborate so we don't need to know how
a flush toilet works we just use it
but we know a plumber who does who can
come and fix it when it goes wrong
it gets worse in another way basically
what cameron says is that we have
two modes of of reasoning
uh one based on system one which is
intuitive
it's emotional it's biased towards
believing it's a
mechanism for jumping to conclusions and
it's what kendaman calls thinking fast
we have another system system two to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or
visit iai.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas